die zahlen von null bis 20 die zahlen
von null bis 20
[Musik]
die lektion beginnt die lektion beginnt
guten morgen
guten morgen guten tag herr studer
guten tag herr studer wir lernen heute
die zahlen von null bis 20 wir lernen
heute die zahlen von null bis 20
los geht's
nein
14 15
16 16
17 sie lief sehen
19 19
wahnsinn
gut und jetzt nochmals nacheinander 0 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19 20
jetzt ihr los geht's jetzt los geht's
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20
bravo bravo
wir machen nach der pause einen test
ring ring pause
[Musik]
der kaffee ist lecker
ich mag kaffee nicht ich mag kaffee
nicht
was magst du was magst du ich mag t
ich mag t
magst du magst du t
ja ich mache auch
ja ich mag t auch
gehen wir zusammen einen tee trinken
gerne wann
ja gerne gewann
hast du am freitag um 17 uhr zeigt
hast du am freitag um 17 uhr zeit
nein am freitag habe ich keine zeit
ruf mich am samstag an
wie ist deine telefonnummer
0 7415 2386 bitte noch einmal
und langsam bitte noch einmal
und langsam
also 0 7415 2386 richtig
ja genau ja genau
und weil copper gold auf ihr großes bier
56 alte heck 78 peter lacht 19 auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
die prüfung beginnt die prüfung beginnt
welche zahl ist das welche zahl ist das
motto
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß es nicht
du weißt es nicht du weißt es nicht
rate mal rate mal 3 10 13 13 ist richtig
13 ist richtig gut geraten peter gut
geraten peter alle haben die prüfung
bestanden alle haben die prüfung
bestanden
gratulation gratulation
[Musik]
www.hhl.de deutsch schule punkt ch bist
du mutig dann drücke hier
möchtest du weitere videos sehen dann
abonniere und maike dankeschön